I feel like Mexican chips and flavors
ten times better than American chips and
flavors smells like a fart a little bit
[Music]
nice con limón cheeto Trudy my so it's
like little churros with lime Oh a lot
of spices visible on the chip which I
like a lot of spices visible in my nose
so wine might be a little much as you do
about the line yeah I mean I feel that
about most lime chips agree whoa flavor
sensation has a punch of lime
now it's delicious muy bien you know
what it's like it's like a shrunken
boudu head version of a churro this is a
trill for mice as a cute little uh
second is that howard the duck i love
how alternative he is he's like I'm a
cool duck I'm an illustrator this is
like a Mexican Twinkie yeah I do like a
weight here give me your half I don't
like it again I didn't like it the first
second I open my mouth Sabri doughnuts I
get that right this is gonna be
delicious
that's a puffed chip that tastes like
Chilean mine look eat it look at all the
spices on this chip there they're
leaving nothing at home they're like
going all out every time
Oh fun it's a party when you first take
a bite it's like this is popcorn and
then you get the spice and then you get
it's a three sensation experience [ __ ]
lattes penis
why'd you say it like that you brought
us to a Mexican taste NASA gave us
Japanese peanuts good can I steal you it
smells like peanuts but it also smells
like the grass in the summer
it smells like grass in the summer all
right doesn't it smell the grass in the
summer and what was the other thing you
said
yeah dead on there like anything yeah
the only they look like what they look
like - yeah not like cartoon food damn
this is delicious
I don't know where what is on you not
just a great crunch I don't understand
what that crunches yeah they put
something on the outside of peanut
[Music]
there's a crisp on this peanut rancher
Ito's yeah I've got a cowboy hat a
bandanna
this is Cool Ranch maybe but the real
ranch oh it's just a Dorito it's the
exact same thing
this is 100% cool ranch Dorito shirts
Cool Ranch Doritos cut in a different
shape and put in a different bags Madame
barbecuey
yeah but like real barbecue like the
smoke from the barbecue why do we have
to have triangles so I can't we have
strips just being a lot more efficient
and I feel like just at first glance a
lot less crumbly in there than a burrito
bag
I feel like Mexicans like spicy flavors
like chili and lime and Americans like
mild ass flavors like cheese and sour
cream
we're like the money this salsa that
exists Yeah right like tomatoes yeah
they're like no no salsa just do you
have enough taste